to say this is blowing up is an
understatement compare frozen on ice to
every other entity in your franchise
we've never quite seen the onslaught of
ticket sales like we've seen for frozen
we went on sale this summer we sold
10,000 tickets within the first hour
over 250,000 tickets in the first 24
hours
we just finished a five-day stint at
Brooklyn Barclays Center we played two
hundred and twelve thousand fans it has
just been mind-blowing
are you selling way more product than at
other shows I'm guessing your
demographic is eight-year-old girls and
showing up to the Barclays center
they're probably in an Elsa costume they
want the light-up wand
they want the Olaf Cup well we're just
seeing consumers consume everything
frozen so I know Disney's seeing it
they're coming into disney on ice
wearing the costumes as you said yes and
they're purchasing lights or experiment
experiential type merchandise I mean
we've sold over 50,000 Olaf snow cone
mugs how much of the upside are insane
they get fifty fifty thousand Olaf mugs
and how much does that mug cost it can
range depending depending on what city
you're in but it runs about twelve to
fifteen dollars
oh oh it's indestructible it'll last you
forever everything comes with a
guarantee can't get it anywhere else how
much I'm curious how much of the upside
that you're seeing as a result of this
unbelievable interest in frozen or maybe
not unbelievable kids dig it flows to
Feld and how much of it flows to Disney
well we're a parasitic business we're a
licensee of the Disney Company I am NOT
able to comment on what Disney's numbers
are of course we're doing very well we
have a great partnership with them
because we're doing well they're doing
well with anything that that is frozen
but you know we also have eight Disney
on I shows that are all very successful
touring domestically and worldwide want
to say that's the first time I've ever
heard anybody say quite happily we're a
parasitic business we are it's a great
it's a great explanation is there
anything you can take away from frozen
success
deliver that to your other on ice
products wait is Marvel on ice or that's
just an action Marvel is a lie it's
alive and living a spectacular also a
Feld Entertainment property I mean
anything that we do it felt
entertainment is a learning for the next
live show so I think with this you know
we've seen the audience involvement
we've added frozen segments into two
other disney on ice shows one that just
opened in poland this past week which
has just been phenomenal and it's just
going to continue the success of Persons
just going to continue to support
everything that we do would felt
entertainment we're able to bring in I
think you know an additional audience
over what we typically do you know this
is audience that have eyes on Feld
Entertainment they're gonna look forward
to see Disney on Ice when it comes again
in January with a princess and hero show
and also Ringling Brothers when it comes
back in the spring and Monster Jam and
everything else we have a Monster Jam
are you going to try to create another
foes at frozen product given how
successful this was well we're very
happy with this shows a nun grab first
frozen is a natural on ice and it makes
for a beautiful transformation from the
film to to this medium we have plans to
include it and update some of our other
disney on ice shows but for the meantime
this shows going to enjoy a 10-month
tour domestically 35 this year into the
beginning of next year it's gonna play
that Mexico City hit the west coast of
the United States next year wouldn't it
be like The Lion King and Mamma Mia and
just go on forever and ever and ever and
ever
well we hope so I mean I don't know
actually ever joke you realize I'm gonna
be done with this I I mean we hope that
this success goes to continue on I don't
know if anything can see this kind of
level forever is this going to be your
most profit haven't you've been in
business for 35 years
that's right is this going to be your
most profitable year ever given that we
haven't seen anything along the lights
of frozen before I mean first of all the
show only opened in fourth quarter of
this year so we're seeing tremendous
lift obviously because of this
phenomenon I mean
it's gonna play - over a million people
by the end of the year actually maybe
even by the end of the month does it
cost more money than your other disney
on ice shows the production is on par
with the level of our I mean take a
price ticket prices are what the market
demands I mean there's definitely a
secondary and third ticket market where
we're seeing inflated prices that that
is not what we're putting out but does
that mean you could then increase your
so does Disney on does frozen on ice if
I buy a ticket from Ticketmaster does it
cost the same thing as heroes on ice or
your princess show on ice it depends
when you go we have we actually um
participate in dynamic pricing so it
depends when you go what the market
demands but you can get a ticket to
frozen on ice starting at $15
that's pretty accessible yeah without a
doubt what what so if it's not going to
be I mean if we're talking about frozen
you talked about some of the other
things that you have in the pipeline
when you look at the way that people
respond to frozen what other ideas does
it give you about things that felt might
staged well I know that anything that
has that kind of great emotional music
is what's gonna be popular with kids and
families so you know as long as Disney
continues to produce really great
intimate animated films with emotion
characters with emotional resonance and
really great music that's gonna do well
for us do you think Disney plays close
attention to what happens in this after
market with Disney on Ice or no but
whether they respond to it whether they
see what happens beyond the film I think
so